persone dovranno badare alla bambola in
questa azienda stasera ero io non voglio
parlare la bambola
di sonorità story
perché perché o ci giocheremo la paura
non si seguita da un botta perché noi
adoriamo le storie paurose adoriamo le
cose paura perché devi comodi presi pop
con rilasciate un mi piace qui sotto
perché in questo video raggiunge i 7.000
vi piace ci sarà un altro gioco pauroso
david o in questo gioco dei portali
paurosi ci sono trattori e paurose da
cui dobbiamo scegliere che se il
compleanno di isabella che sembra non
sembra horror però non si sa cosa
potrebbe succedere oppure c'è il
carnevale di jolly
forse c'è un pagliaccio qua e voi c'è
l'ospedale g force quali si chiama direi
di partire con la prima no quindi
compleanno di tabella ma se voi volete
che giochiamo anche alle altre storie mi
raccomando mi piace questo test ai nomi
seguiti ancora si insabbiano andate a
seguire una vanitas toys iniziamo con il
compleanno ed isabelle vediamo cosa gli
aspetta la prima volta che vieni qui
scegli una modalità
spaventoso divertimento
spaventoso ok
va bene
è infatti c'è che per gente in questo
spaventoso guarda quanti siamo
siamo in tanti perché perché dobbiamo
andare a guarda qua c'è scritto gioca
penso che dobbiamo andare qua sei sono
le altrui o credevi seguimi
prenderò io
partecipo al partito è
sembrato alla fatica in attesa di tre
giocatori ma dobbiamo per forza giocare
in
pochi sono riusciti fotograto per
evitare cosa ci aspetterà prima di
sapere che cosa succede indovinate cosa
succederà come isabelle nel nome di una
bambina home aleksic a oggi una bambola
potrebbe essere bambola verifica secondo
voi cosa succederà perché sei attendere
per favore il cui video scriveteci nei
commenti quanto era paurosa questo gioco
da 110 anche noi vi diremo prendono e
conterà pauroso da 1 a 10 party la festa
sta iniziando non è che sia una festa di
compleanno vivere sembra tutto
normalissimo a dobbiamo salire sul bus
dove sei io sono qui comandiamo su
quello bianco dai ocmmedia.com io no ma
non si può salire ei no non mi fa salire
a siamo entrati in casa
e sara isabella è un giocatore e tu ti
sei seduto da solo na buon compleanno
dove isabella
ok mettetevi nelle vostre posizioni
dobbiamo parlare che copiano sono dei
punti verdi per nasconderti ok
mi sono nascosto
ok io sono qua quindi dobbiamo giocare a
nascondino
forse è quello che un orsacchiotto che
mi piace mio outfit non posso credere
che mi abbiate organizzato una festa di
compleanno a sorpresa pensavo che tutti
si dimenticassero come l'ultima volta no
no non c'è modo che dimenticherò mai il
compleanno del mio migliore amico
non ringraziarmi non c'è non ce l'avrei
fatta senza l'aiuto di tutti 23 di villa
festa ragazzi
ok andiamo lì ti la festa per diciotto
secondi è un tool breve questa fetta la
velocissima aveva detto erakat ha per
vedere se gli fai un sogno io devo
andare
dove la cucina
cucina detto sia più della stessa
qualche notizia si è meglio che
cerchiamo è uscita
[Musica]
come cisco succedendo
ecco un regalo che ho scelto per te che
non siano state le mele sionista fatto
che tradotto non sarai mai mia madre mai
angoli la mamma isabella madre
non hai mai chiesto se volevo una madre
una nuova madre non mi hai mai chiesto
dei miei sentimenti
non voglio sentirlo io odio
voleva una nuova padre per il compleanno
non sapendo che diciamo diamo tutta
volendo per fortuna quindi isabella e
arrabbiata perché il padre non ha mai
chiesto di essere i sentimenti e le gole
fanno nuova madre per il suo compleanno
se n'è andata non posso lei era proprio
lì in lei chi aspetta la nostra isabella
dobbiamo dare subito voi due dovete
spiegare seriamente è costato più
spiegare il mio precedente foresta
quindi isabelle scappate perché non ha
ricevuto una nuova madre il compleanno e
ora stiamo andando nella foresta a
cercarla ok andiamo con con questa
maglia di buio stiamo aspettando i
giocatori infatti non possiamo salire in
macchina e sbrigativi non voglio stare
troppo tempo poi al buio cosa ci sarà
nella foresta mi sa che nel gargano e la
foresta inizierà la parte più paurosa
dai sbrigatevi dobbiamo cercare sta bene
state qua ad aspettare anche se un po 3
alla parte lesa bella allora non
possiamo perderci dobbiamo sistemare un
campo è intendi un campeggio e aiutateci
a trovare legna per il fuoco mentre io
amber kate
organizziamo io sto seguendo questo
percorso dobbiamo trovare della legna e
non mi ricordo che cos'altro ma io non
risalto alla foresta
bene
strade
vado verso il laghetto
per fortuna sembra molto più caldo come
questa per portarvi cui parli è metterci
qua ora se ci fosse se ci perdiamo
possiamo trovare la strada per tornare
al campo al nero o quasi posso ritrovare
[Applauso]
che cos'è un coniglio che cos'è si
suderà visto inseguendo credono parte
orrori
io sto scappando proprio sultan a
mio carico
[Musica]
dove bay boh io sono stufo dall'altra
parte mi sarà
d'aiuto
non
sono ancora vita
io sto brancolando nel buio guarda che
le tende sono sopra sono alzate
dispiacerebbe spiegare tutte queste urla
ma come non hai fatto niente
c'era qualche fantasma che cercava di
ucciderci tutti
era un fantasma qualcuno probabilmente
un coniglio selvatico è carino ma non
era né cari non è innocuo
qualunque cosa fosse isabella era in
pericolo dobbiamo trovarla in fretta sì
se da sola con quel questa sorta di
coniglio mi ricordo che mi piaceva a
venire qui spesso se conoscessi meglio
mia figlia sarebbe allo stagno
ok andiamo allo stagno
aspettate ragazzi dove infatti io non so
mai dove se quel sentiero b con torelli
che hanno lo seguivamo il sentiero
questa è la matrigna di isabella ho
sentito che accadono brutte cose qui a
quest'ora della notte sei me ne sono
accorta
meglio tornato siamo arrivati attaccati
e quello non era un coniglio molto bene
sia un brutto presentimento per lo
stadio il più velocemente possibile
calza sbrighiamoci per una voce ora se
volete velocemente andiamo lo stagno
velocista finissimo 45 secondi aiuto no
no no no no no voglio parlare cosa
capiti preda ma tu sarebbe avere la
spagna non ho dovuto seguire un percorso
immagino non so dove in seguito
35 si continua si
dovere percorso non lo sono gli altri
allora meglio seguire qualcuno di loro
magari avevano da me 23 secondi la
faremo mai vista ecco che cosa le parole
del mondo sbrigati ok anche a te ci sono
corri parrebbero tu fai lo stagno tenevi
cinico ultimo solo di rivendita allora
laghetto di qua
sbrigativi
mauro
sei morto
no non sono tanto fare con questi già
che avevamo selezionare un altra cosa lì
ma che cos'è questo qualcuno intenzione
di terrore interrogare la bambola
inquietante cosa
l'ultimo chiamare così e mia figlia è
una bambola quella non è isabella stai
zitto so che questa isabella lo so e
basta ok è impazzito il padre
ok forse siamo tutti stanchi per questa
infinita corsa in giro sono d'accordo
forse dovremmo riposarci un po e
riprovare domattina quando giorno si
fatevi riportare dallo spavento di prima
va bene ma alcune persone dovranno
badare alla bambola in questa azienda
stasera però io non mi vogliono pagare
alla bambola isabella potrebbe darci un
indizio su come farla tornata alla
normalità ma la scusa isabella da
bambola
suona bene la brava bene non essere choc
quella non è isabella non dormi nella
mia tenda per stanotte è sicuramente non
voglio dormire con la bombola valle
campiona entra nell'azienda con un ambra
o entrano nella tenda con la bambola
io vado con ambra ok tu dove sei
io sono in questa con la bambola però
non posso più uscire ma cosa sola
secondi tu sei andato da nababbo nate
quando vitale addio per sempre
sicuramente non sopravvivere sono morto
cosa è successo
che cos'è successo
non ne sono sicuro ma forse se seguiamo
questa traccia di sangue avremo delle
risposte
più possibile questa traccia di sangue
non è il momento per un po di sangue
isabella è andata dove dove è scappata
già non riesco neanche a trovare amber e
scappate anche lei dovremmo seguire le
tracce di sangue
non dobbiamo tornare allo stagno a chi
crediamo
forse
se questa molto nello stagno
aiuto prima che il sangue se potrei ok
se può
capitarmi di billy quindi tu sei morto
all'improvviso è diventato tutto buio
solo è scritto sei aveva detto di non
andare dalla bambola è così arrivati qua
questa casa che adesso che dobbiamo fare
cosa sta succedendo pure che esca
l'altra cosa all'improvviso si imbarcò
ho detto ci siete cascati
uno scherzo questa isabella e queste
amber avresti dovuto vedere gli sguardi
sui loro volti non posso credere che tu
l'abbia fatto sei andata troppo oltre
una trappola di tabella
[Musica]
un po inquietante
ma cosa sta succedendo dopo aver dato io
chi è
e coniglio
mai vista parlano la barba di aver fatto
irruzione in casa
non te ne andrai vivi comunque e
miracolo se tu dici tu
questa casa dovrebbe essere abbandonata
anno credo anch'io perché c'è una
bambola con la barba invece bastano
attende
è crollata la casa moon ha vissuto né a
scappare dal mio seminterrato ok dai
questa sarà che ti queste vi interrotto
e questo a
me non parlare più commovente è corta
hai mai non esco dal tar e
50 secondi i principi salta salta
attenta quella lampadina perché secondo
me se sbatti lì ti fai male
brava
si fa sì bravo
o no si muovono queste mattonelle tra
l'altro brava
più veloce chiamano quanto tempo manca
24 23 sentito la natura brava brava
brava l'hai
non ci credo che se ce la puo fare
cellulare
non ci credo all'ultimo momento solo fa
e dietro di noi dobbiamo sbrigarci ma ho
visto ancora inseguendo questa porta non
si apre e adesso
chi è
e come se non che nasconde
mantica
aiuto
viene moriremo tutti
siete ancora nascosta si
sono scappati dovrò portare il coltello
o no c'è qualcosa in questa stanza che
potremmo usare non visto trova qualcosa
e over solo in questa scatola forse
qualcosa
no non trovo niente lo aiuto
di chi sarà o no
apri sesamo mi ha donato la chiave e
billy ha trovato la fiamma e ancora
è apparsa
ricorrere
[Applauso]
all'uso che ansia
lo vedete tutti i testi sta colpendo
dovete votare non saprei
[Musica]
[Applauso]
pato ea
aiuto
amato punto finisce
spesso riprendete stiamo scappando temi
se stiamo scappando dalla bombola quella
macchina non parte
pure questa ci mancava
questa sono questi rumori
ti ha mandato la medaglia però ho preso
un badge ma non ho capito che per che
per ora è completato la storia è
guadagnata 500 manette un punto per gli
animali domestici
è riuscito a completarla non lo so bene
il belgio che ha un regio è il finale
normale e in realtà ci sono anche altri
finali base alle cose che fai ma se
folletti che proviamo le altre storie
paurose lasciato belli
piazzale voto diamo da una di alcuni
secondo me si merita un bel otto e mezzo
perché alla cina era bello spaventoso ma
anche intrigante bella storia anche se
voi dovete non lo capite cioè tabella
sempre stata accolta con ambra però può
essere una barbara cola barbara tipo uno
scherzo ma lascia un po a quattro
gallerie triplicare per vedere i nostri
altri video cercate su quella che
preferite
buona visione